but in general right the kill stage
taking thunderstruck overall first place
I don't think he had to run into beneath
there as I know beneath was there but I
think they actually had a play in
Bradley I think they did yeah so because
the kill sage dodged even their God
first place that he's generally
considered to be one of the strongest
dragon ball players in the United States
so was he being he riding that momentum
of course taking first place had a 10k
EEG event already he's got plenty of
points but he wants more wants to ensure
that he gets into the finals we got
happy sage and a very happy looking
apology man which is surprising me right
Paul g-man usually looks like he's just
kind of he's a meditating like piccolo
oh I see okay sure no he's a adopted
that the namekian techniques
maybe one day aim for the stars he's
gotta go balls first
just like Niccolo oh god yeah now Steve
Jim was talking about how there's like a
whole like a bald man gang like in that
you have to worry about Jordan got to be
mess well no I mean if I melt my hair
off maybe but like you know voluntarily
joint airily joint but yeah he was
talking about it he was saying like
vicious is a part of it yeah Wow okay
vicious I wonder if we're probably not
gonna have a button check with these two
I don't feel like saying as one of those
I got their game faces on yeah looks
like we're getting right
Wow or is in the process of quite get in
range Wow speaking of giving rage
apology man with the sword normal from
long distance going right into the
health it up put need to claim at snap
meta it's got it you got to be careful
about it Bucky's here
piccolo really good at bugging people
not gonna get at that but gonna be
carrot that have to be scary being girly
against especially Paul Newman's piccolo
oh yeah and again now snapping in the
team going on see if you can survive the
hell's on your name big stuff does not
hit someone the dome as soon as he lands
yeah apology man is absolutely abusing
to kill fate in the corner right now how
long the kills has gonna play this game
before he sparks their status yeah I I
think it's smart especially on parolee
you don't want to deal with that yeah
most definitely nice bottom apology man
including the instant air dashes after
the 6 mm is he setting up with a grab
I'm thinking that he's trying to
condition to him right now
yeah oh what a great just gets hit again
and the sparking is gone so to Kissinger
is just gonna have to hold this or hopes
that he makes the right move whether to
reflect or not incredibly impressive
start from apology man here going right
back into the game
then go hard kill sage waiting for the
higher law yeah talk about this thing
never think he was gonna have to like
block low or overhead there and you get
scraps not what's he gonna do to the
Rolly actually takes the hit this time
apology man getting both those assists
bag including yeah the goal crews super
Saiya Jim doesn't go for theaters Posey
then jumps out of the law gravity cannot
escape this corner special beam cannon
enough damage with just one bar on that
Barry last hit one character down
Brawley on death's door and no sparking
fatigue as somebody calls who is that
which others
nice going right into the team going on
for the proper extension here it's gonna
be able to kill them off with two level
ones right back in the piccolo as well
man apology man is rolling he's barely
touched right now by to kill sage which
is insane trying to catch them woodland
out but apology max has been solely
solid on defense I like the challenge
for the piccolo beam or the piccolo ball
with the ki blast of Goku getting rid of
that quick okay going for the jump hit
oh okay those foods I see black but gets
blown up here the corner beneath is
gonna spark great option right there
from beneath right because if you get
hit by the 6m then you're negative so he
just goes for the reflect obviously
comes out in one frame reads it and
because of that he was able to look what
the 2h and the beam on the other side
and the vanish which means yes would
pull punish level three into the level
five and that's going to be game one
what a strong game from apology man
there he woke up he had his cereal with
his warm milk and he is just ready to go
he has put the ball outside like they
eat it warm it up spark off the brawl is
you made to kill stage angry yeah you
stepped on Android 16 head in front of
them Auto combo pitching the raw tire
out there just teen gohan things
yeah great back - you picked up team go
on after I pick up teeth Gohan it's true
but let me remind you welcome down again
they're brought from the hope players
yeah the killings looking for something
you saw the counter notification maybe
you thought that Denise was gonna
respect to come back off yeah good night
and we are playing the snap role he gets
pumped the air to air you have another
counter hit the kill stage trying to
find his way out just the lowly he
doesn't get out of this forest equation
I don't think we'll see piccolo come out
this yet but we might see a super year
keep snapping it seems like a good idea
though goes for the loan
beautiful stuff locking them down with
the goal Cruces making them guess I'm
gonna get right back into it
I feel like - like apology ants team
it's one of those teams like mid range
so they'll hate but it's a corner just
it's just so hard to deal with and we're
seeing that right now with the kill page
I wanted to set up with that hell's on
after he's gonna be able to reflect all
of it no like bethlo apology man just
backing up waiting for the raw attacked
with the kill sage one step ahead not
giving it to him safely gets Broly in
here we go right to the level three with
Crowley
wait I thought he was waiting for the
wrong - no - Asian the gills angeletti
gets heated up by the legs you saw the
flash of armor as well he tried
something with Brawley but man the legs
have so many hits and he just got hit
right over the don't with those legs
they are literally the new shotgun of
this game well not even knew they
statement they bent shotguns they just
had to put him back on the character
selection he was banned for a little bit
was unsuccessful it's good to see that
kill stage taking a little bit of that
blue health back from when he pulled out
pink go on oh I try for the demon of all
only finds the lows from the co sage I'm
gonna be able to fight knockdown in the
level 1 in the level 1 and that's gonna
kill caught me how many huh all right
at least Piccolo's out of the way here
but to kill stage has a long road ahead
of him if he still wants to take this
game against apology man but that auto
combo why is he in the corner after that
as well positive as doesn't Spartan
gotta keep that in mind can't convert
off the team Gohan is this now arguably
even
oh right into the heavy legs straight
choice there oh but drops the Congo
there he has a big damage starter if I
can't make the most of it
Oh a great reflex potties there from the
kilts age I was sold clean got volume at
be playing a little reckless here
because he has that sparking he's gonna
lose one of his characters because of it
it's a scary place to be even with that
sparking still left because Super Saiyan
Goku is a survivor
oh yeah he's not gonna give up all right
I got apology man finally caught in that
spark with the tteyuu ohon again this is
the newest addition to his team the
character he's the most experienced with
most the other side while you can try to
to anciently tried to cover his whip
with his own vanish and that is a habit
a lot of Dragon Ball fighters players
have you see them with you just gotta
wait they will vanish and to H citty oh
the back off into the jump in double axe
handle that same lineage paying off here
for
level three and we're gonna see it it's
all about the kills they surviving this
nexus marking has gone for apology man
work yeah because they don't come back
from this it's just gonna take at least
two hits here both players go play real
just when is point about the key blast
we checked off what we need about one
more maybe rocket legs to the face this
could easily be death right there and
apology man's gonna take it over to kill
six sending him to the losers side of
the bracket and that was a winners
qualifying match no apology man gonna be
in top fate winners sighs that's a good
look for him and you mentioned before
the match right the kill stage talked
about an apology man being his demon
having a like one of the worst
tournament records against him as well
like the overall players are concerned
and man could see why apology man just
seems to have his number
he really has him on his watch he was
ready for everything and to kill six
just for how experienced of a player
that to kill sage is he just really
wasn't able to get out of that corner no
matter how much he tried especially in
that first game it was like he got one
chance on offensive momentum and apology
man blocked everything and then jumped
out of the throw and as soon as that
happened he took his momentum back
sparking was gone you had no resources
to get out because that's what this ten
minute brings right we talked about it
yesterday the only resource you have
once you get a character snapped in it
is the sparking on defense you can't
guard canceled you can't raw tag you
can't do any of that so because of that
the snap man is very strong forcing to
play with one character an apology man
played it to perfection